[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
yes
excuse me
yeah shut up happy Tuesday everybody now
if you think America has made any great
strides and civil rights over the last
50 years you couldn't be more wrong just
a few years after our first black
president and our first orange one
things are worse than ever and CNN's got
the memes to prove it that's right memes
you know those pictures or videos
typically with a funny caption that your
Uncle Lou sends the whole family on
Facebook after he convinces himself he's
the only one who's seen them
there is varied as they are tiresome the
crying Michael Jordan meme the
distracted boyfriend meme even Joe Biden
falling off his bike became a meme
and of course you could forget this meme
or this one
yeah
and of course this one
[Laughter]
yeah but apparently memes are now a tool
of white supremacy just like everything
else these days that's according to CNN
whites sharing memes with black people
in them is racist because if there's one
thing racist love it's looking at black
people CNN calls it digital blackface
it's sad where there isn't racism CNN
just has to invent it they're so
desperate for relevance that they'll
push division any way they can CNN.com
writer John Blake writes that digital
blackface is quote where white people
co-opt online expressions of black
imagery slang catchphrases or culture to
convey comic relief or to express
emotions and inadvertently perpetuate
one of the most Insidious forms of
contemporary racism he adds put simply
digital blackface is 21st century
minstrelsy Minstrel C that's how it's
spelled
to which I can only respond with this
that's right I just committed digital
blackface
I doubt it's worse than the traditional
liberal version of blackface
mine's much easier on the pores now if
you happen to love Fred Sanford as much
as I do and you meme him that's a
racialized reaction because he's black
and what if I use Eddie Murphy giving
the A-Okay sign that's got to make Joy
Reed's head explode
no worries if that happens there's no
mess to clean up
so you memed Murphy that means according
to John Blake you co-opted culture what
a pathetic idiot it's like he believes
he had a role in that culture and
therefore he must protect it oh you
White Knight sorry Black Knight in fact
all of these accusers of cultural
appropriation foolishly think that they
can be a custodian to a history that
they had no role in they didn't make
Sanford and Son they had nothing to do
with Beverly Hills Cop now imagine of
all of us embraced their beliefs that
all cultures must be separated that the
only people who would be eligible for
antibiotics would be white British males
because it's their culture after all
literally
but see we don't care Idris Elba playing
a Norse God have at it that's What
actors do hell you could remake crazy
Rich Asians with Native Americans and I
could give it
I can already see who plays the mom
growing up in the late 90s
I was taught America was a Melting Pot
where all different kinds of people
could get along now that pot's gone cold
and the only melting we see is Nancy
Pelosi's face
now we're seeing calls for cultural and
racial re-segregation we've replaced
patriotism with identity politics so
instead of unifying under one idea we
divide into tribes which is how the
media wants it races fighting each other
instead of them and make no mistake this
new separatism is racism it's just
repackaged like when CNN moved Don Lemon
to the morning show
racial separatists like to say things
like my culture is not your costume as
if culture is something to be hoarded
instead of shared but there are oddly
enough exceptions like when Dylan
Mulvaney a male or once a male co-ops an
entire gender mocking it with girly
stereotypes and still lands an interview
with our senile president Poor Joe Biden
he probably thought Audrey Hepburn
needed a shave
but again I don't care we're not in a
division that's bigotry especially since
the same people saying that you
shouldn't enjoy other cultures are the
same ones who complain that if you leave
out minorities you're erasing them
sorry this is America and you're free to
participate in our Rich diverse culture
in its entirety that's the whole damn
point of this place you can use any meme
you want you can sing any song you want
unless it's maroon 5.
then capital punishment is the only
option
[Applause]
can't put in a box vice president nmpr
for the wellness company that sounds
mysterious Chris Barron
he's not sitting on a porcupine he just
looks like he is
[Applause]
writer and comedian Joe Mackey
she's like a ceramic tile often found on
the bathroom floor Fox News contributor
captain
foreign
and he once gave Paul Bunyan a wedgie my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrese
Tyrus I go to you first for no
particular reason uh-huh no do you agree
that memes can be a form of white
supremacy no listen to meme saying I'm a
white supremacist
that's a great meme
I think they're gonna be like right like
they still wouldn't believe you yeah
this is the nail hopefully the final
nail in the coffin for CNN like this
this is insulting and ridiculous you
know the fact Michael Jordan literally I
think everyone in here has something in
their closet somewhere with a swish on
it yes Michael Jordan transcended didn't
change the game and when he cried it was
a big deal and everyone did and everyone
posted it it's a it's a it's a a term of
endearment that you have transcended so
many things when you make a comment or a
funny statement or a meme that everyone
from all walks of life creating color
wants to be a part of it that could not
be more of a greater show of lack of
racism in this country to where we can
all laugh together I post memes and
videos of Don Rickles all the time so
now my anti-jew like how stupid is that
I love the guy and all even though if I
was sitting in his audience he would
have destroyed me and I would have loved
every second of it
but you know it's amazing what you just
said
it's it's an example of how the left and
the woke in general are against sharing
like sharing is a sign of something bad
when in fact we should be celebrating I
celebrate all the time I get an email
from somebody from like careers like
you're my favorite wrestler I don't be
like how dare you
sir yes
you know like you you Embrace that you
love that you want people from all walks
of life to laugh at you with you that's
the whole point of the memes yeah so you
know it again it's over yeah it's going
to be CN though yeah just take the end
off take the end off
instead of CNN it should be Sia complete
nonsense that's what they are Joe how
you doing I'm doing good Greg I've got
uh I I think Tyrus can back me up on
this I've got my finger on the pulse of
Black America
and they are tired of of adding things
to be offensive you know yeah when I was
a kid the only two words you couldn't
say were the n-word and irregardless yes
and I thought that was a better world
it's not the problem that we're we got
so many things that are offensive it's
that we're adding so many offensive
things
a lot of people just weren't made fun of
enough when they were kids so they can't
they can't deal with it you know we
needed more bullying yeah we I mean when
you say something that offends someone
they put the person that said that into
sensitivity training when it should be
the other way around exactly
that's a great Point Chris why is why is
CNN still doing this weren't they
supposed to turn that truck around and
become kind of like sane here's here's
my question what is the editorial
process okay I mean honestly like it's
fine like this guy is trying to like get
as many clicks as possible but you have
an editorial process in place so that
insane stuff doesn't actually end up you
know on your website and here the people
the the Brain Trust that CNN got
together and was like I think this is a
great idea the dude actually used the
words the most Insidious form of racism
not just its kind of racist it's a
little racist like literally this is
cross burning inching habit this is the
most Insidious form of racism is sharing
ain't nobody got time for that Meme yes
that's it that's the most Insidious form
no it's crazy it's crazy well they
always have to make whatever they're
talking about seem worse than whatever
they talked about before they can't say
this is bad but it's not as bad as the
other thing that I was talking about
before because that's really boring Kat
how do you feel about memes in general I
have mixed feelings I feel like they're
like like catchphrases in a way that
they kind of replace thinking you know
I'm so tired of the one of those guys in
suits dancing do you know that everybody
posts that Meme do you know what I'm
talking about they're like at a garden
party yeah I have friends who will
always respond in the chat with like a
gif or a meme I'm like can you just talk
to me please yeah uh but I mean I don't
think that that many people are really
that upset about this I did see one guy
who was like thankfully CNN's talking
about this we have to let people know
and then I go to his Twitter apparently
he wrote a book called the case for
cancel culture
um but basically what they're saying is
that if you're a white person you can't
share it because you know you you can't
unders you know there could never be a
thought or a feeling that a black person
that was expressing that you could
relate to so basically that is placing
the words and thoughts and feelings of
black people into a separate category
from the rest of humans and to me that
is what sounds a little racist actually
what's your favorite meme I don't have a
I don't know if you have a favorite meme
then I'm sorry
I think you just made a meme I think the
great thing about this show is we just
made three memes how to kill Mead and
those are going to be everywhere just
like kill me
well no he just never leaves the
building actually
if you need me I'm here yes that's
that's his meme if you need me I'm here
we should get one like hey kill me go
home yes hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else